welcome everybody to today's meeting of
the cabinet those that are participating
and those who are watching on the
livestream if members have technical
difficulties during the meeting then
please contact the Democratic services
officer on call we will attempt to
assist you and today's the democratic
services officer is Charlotte Crowley
and in the numbers 5 double 7 193 it
also be at the top of the chat thread
for members to read from them as if you
need it but those of you who are
watching by the council's you that you
should screen please follow the
instructions below the video if there
are any issues with the live for lead
and asked participants that when you're
not speaking please to mute your
microphone this minimizes background
noise and will help everyone listening
to the proceedings microphones must only
be on if the participant has been
greeted permission to speak to gain my
permission to speak please very briefly
indicate on the chat to the right at the
side of the screen and I will make a
note and get back to you once the person
speaking is finished obviously we're all
getting used to these arrangements but
please note that we'll be following the
usual Cabinet protocols in which other
members of the council usually only
speak once on each item we don't
everyone please ensure that their mobile
phones are turn to silent they're not
used to make or receive calls while the
meeting is in progress please also
refrain from checking emails or
conducting other business and ensure
that you're in a quiet room free from
distractions for the duration of the
meeting these note the meetings being
live-streamed members of the public
it will also be recorded and will be
subsequently available on the internet
so first of all can ask the members of
cabinet to confirm that they're present
in the meeting when I read out their
name I've been asked for the attendance
those counselors who are participating
in order to speak under council
procedure or 20.1 separately so
counselor Whitehead present counselor
Alvin here absolute that willeth here I
can't see Yates
yep present thank you the following
members have asked to speak under
counsel procedural 20.1 so when I say
your name please confirm that you're
present in the meeting item for
councillor Beauford it here Taryn
Thank You counselor garden present item
five counselor Ashby present item six
counselor Rogers present you could buy
some seven counselor heart yeah Chet
your counselor town president thank you
I like some eight counselor gonna over
here counselor game is already heard
from but she's asked to speak on the
item and cowslip you know counselor Pew
okay so can't sleep you doesn't appear
to be here at the moment we'll see
though of these here when we get to
isolate or any other counselors
president who wish to speak under
counsel procedural 20.1 silence so we
should assume they're on there are no
apologies for absence cuz all the
cabinet are here does anyone have an
interest to declare in the items
business on the agenda this evening
there's no response I assume that's and
now move on to item three the minutes of
the previous meeting to approve the
summary of recommendations and decisions
of the cabinet meeting held on the 23rd
of April 2020
I'll propose the minutes diverse
seconder well second them take a look my
counselor Duckworth and this I hear any
objection I'll take those minutes as
approved objection came there now so to
take those as approved and we'll move on
to item 4 which is the fact local plan
inspectors report and reduction I should
find the right document talk about that
so this is the second visit of the
fennec local plan in its Lane is formed
to cabinet and we're now moving into the
very final stage hopefully of adopting
it the plan is part of the council's
policy framework and therefore has to be
adopted by meeting of the formal council
and is scheduled to go to full council
on the 9th of July
a brief reprieve or where we've been the
draft local plan was submitted for
independent examination in October 2018
hearings commenced on the 2nd of April
2019 and finished on the 18th of july
2019 following the examination the
planning inspectors recommended a number
of modifications to the draft plan and
these proposed modifications were
subject to a public consultation
inspectors now considered the
representations major in the
consultations submitted their report to
the council which is attached to the
report annex 1 inspectors are required
to make a judgement about the soundness
of the draft plan the overall conclusion
of their report is that the draft plan
is sound subject to the adoption of the
modifications recommended within their
report and the modifications are at saks
dynamics to the final draft of the local
plan incorporating the inspections
recommended modifications is attached to
this report annex 3 this report
recommends that the modified local plan
be recommended to fall Council for
adoption as indeed it was when we last
met on April the 23rd and the report
also recommends that the landscape
character assessment be adopted as a
supplementary planning document so we
cabinet recommended the revised plan and
the landscape character assessment the
last time we met but part of the process
of governance is it goes to overview
scrutiny for consideration and I think
counsel of paper is going to talk to us
about what overview and scrutiny report
sit back on that and I will respond to
those points but I don't think they'll
affect the plan as its put forward so at
this stage I'm going to remove the
recommendations in the report
do I have a second to place that bit a
second
seconded by councillor Yates and I've
got a call on councillor Beaufort please
right Thank You chairman you can hear me
can you yeah excellent good yes you
rightly say this came to overview and
scrutiny came actually on the 26th of
May and when we were looking forward to
that meeting it was a bit of a shaker to
realise that this was the culmination of
a process that had started in 2009 so
there are over 10 years in the making
and I became aware that
some of us had been around a long time
so probably know more about local plan
and it's good for any person other than
a planner to know about it but that
there are other members that perhaps
weren't familiar with what was going on
and that thought process work was
heightened if you like or highlighted
the meter to those take some sort of
action when rumors started circulating
that in fact avian scrutiny we could
rewrite the local plan now that clearly
wasn't something that we could do and I
felt that members needed to have some
comfort about what they couldn't
couldn't do and to that end I asked
Adrienne Burrell to produce a briefing
document he did so he put the local plan
and the process into some kind of
context when some detail about the
history some of the issues that were
important to the local plan and perhaps
more importantly clarified why it was
important that we had a local plan that
was current our current one being the
earth one were using at the moment being
significantly out of date and it's point
out the implications of not having a
plan that briefing document I would
commend to all members of the council to
read before the council meeting because
it covers an awful lot of points that
are really important I think it has to
be said that members probably felt a
little bit frustrated about the limited
action that was available to us and it's
fair to say that I think we took an
awful lot of comfort in the fact that
the there will have to be a review
within six months of the local plan
being adopted so that any points of a
current in the plan of members run happy
about they could actually make
representation at that point there was a
good debate about the local plan at the
meeting and amongst the points that were
raised by members that they're asking
cabinet or indeed the the Working Party
to look at the review to consider was
whether climate emergency working group
and the local plan review cabinet
advisory group could work
collaboratively
so the issues that may emerge from the
working group could be perhaps
incorporated in the revised local plan
when it comes to review there was
concern that there were green
infrastructure projects that perhaps had
been missed out and there was a request
for those typical tat down valley woods
was recited as a case in point there was
some concern about the way that the Pope
was represented in the local plan and
there was a suggestion that there should
be more consideration given to what part
of the economic development of fanuc
could be affected by the pole there was
suggestion that employment and community
wealth creation should be highlighted in
the new plan it was paint made clear
that there was some concern about the
fact that the draft plan was developed
world before Co bid 90 hitters and there
was questions as to how flexible the new
plan would be to address the challenges
that might be posed in the postcode bid
world or the new normal as people talked
about there was some concerns to weather
delayed decision regarding Menston
Airport could affect the plan there was
a note that potential agricultural land
would be lost through the current
proposals in the plane and the question
was asked that if brownfields became
available in the future could these be
used to replace the greenfield sites
that were currently being proposed there
was a question as to whether the plan
could be reviewed earlier than the six
months I'm not quite sure what the point
that was but one of the members was
concerned about that and the question
about how sort of planning applications
that might fall between the two how they
might be considered so the upshot was
that in the end panel members agreed
that subject to note in the comments
that are just made have been passed on
to cabinet that the panel recommends
that a local plan proposals in the
inspectors main modifications before did
to cabinet and then to council for
approval thank you thank you cancer
Beauford I don't propose to pick up the
point
in scrutiny raised because as you've
said they can't be incorporated into the
plan that we're referring to Council but
I think you should take it as read that
cabinet has heard what through 'tony
members said and we understand the
concerns that were expressed and
certainly we'll be looking at a lot
number of those issues in the review
process I think some quite comprehensive
answers were given out of your scrutiny
by mr. Verrill which are in the minutes
but I'll let mr. Verrill come in a nice
appointment if he's got anything to add
then he can yes so I think we we welcome
and thank scrutiny for the comments that
they made and I would share the
frustration frankly of some of the
members that we're being asked to adopt
a document which hasn't really even been
adopted by the council since 2018
different members of the council and the
world has moved on since then but as you
so eloquently explained that is the
planning process I'm not sure if you
were actually the only member of the
council it was on the council at the
time when the process started I'm trying
to struggle to think who else might been
on the council in 2009 possible possibly
counselor candle yeah no you probably
would have yeah I think we share the
pain
I mean he's private an active part in
the planning system I'm so I'll bring
I'll give mr. Berman opportunity to
comment while bringing counselor games
Thank You chair I think that councillor
Beaufort and with your response have
covered most of what I was going to say
about the plan I would just reiterate
what councilor Beaufort said we need a
sound local plan this has got to be in
place there are doubts as councillor
Davis said there is a six-month review
so those who do doubt it
compare that in mind but if we don't
have a sound local plan and it's not
adopted the risk is just too great thank
you thank you cancer though I think we
do have political unanimously on that
certainly across the two major groups on
the council and I was hope the other
groups because clearly it will be a very
strange situation if we were to reject
this opportunity to let cook glad and I
just asked mr. Barrow if he wants to
come in and make any comments on what's
been said what's all been already been
said by yourself and the other members
thank you well I didn't want you to feel
that we weren't calling on your
expertise mr. Barrow that say as you say
I think we've covered with characters
covered this territory a number of times
already in different meetings and no
doubt we'll cover it again at full
council on to the other ninth
so cabinets been asked to recommend to
council to adopt the planet local plan
subject to the modifications to height
in the inspectors report and adopt the
landscape character assessment as a
supplementary planning document and
that's been moved and seconded unless I
hear an objection I'll take these as
recommended to counsel and there are no
objections so we'll take that has been
recommended adoption recommendations
been adopted and we move on to item 5
which is the East Cape Housing
transition costs and I call on councilor
wide
good evening all
just checking I've actually managed to
switch my microphone on would you like
me to start by reading the
recommendations or go straight into the
introduction time lapse you canceled my
okay
recommendations as they stand cabinet is
asked to approve a 20 20 to 21 only
supplementary HRA revenue budget of a
hundred and eighty-seven thousand pounds
for the transition of the single housing
management system to TDC in house
management to be funded from HRA
balances and approve a recurring 2020 to
21 supplementary HRA revenue budget of
82,000 pounds for the ongoing
maintenance and support of the housing
management system to be funded from HRA
balances in 2020 to 21 and incorporated
into the budget setting process for 20
21 22 and beyond and the reasons for
this are as follows
last October cabinet agreed to bring
in-house the management to the housing
service currently Thurman's housing
management service is provided by East
Kent housing who provide the same
services to three other East Kent
districts all four districts agreed to
end the management agreement on the 17th
of February cabinet received a report
that delegated authority to the deputy
chief executive and section one five one
officer to incur costs of up to two
hundred and fifty thousand pounds in
respect to the transfer this report
explains the background and
justification as to why this delegation
needs to be extended as a result of the
costs of transferring the IT system from
East Kent housing to the four districts
including fact East Kent housing operate
and Northgate housing system they have
been implementing the system for a
considerable time with cost and time
overruns the implementation of the
system still needs to be completed
before it can be broken up into four
separate systems
Northgate runs on server which has
reached the end of its useful life
coupled with this council's desire to
move such systems to a cloud environment
now would be the time to make the switch
the version of north gate being used by
use Kent Housing is out of date and
needs to be brought up to date as well
as moved to the cloud
various options have been considered by
this and by the other councils we have
agreed that the best option is to finish
the original implementation move it to
the cloud separate the system and
database into four and bring it up into
its latest version this is an expensive
and complex task and the estimated costs
are provided in the report these costs
will exceed the twenty two hundred and
fifty thousand pounds delegated
authority so the report is seeking a
separate decision in bringing your
housing back in-house we have a chance
to create a service for our tenants it
exemplifies best practice across all
areas but to do so we need to provide a
secure base to operate from in terms of
system management I move the
recommendations I
Castle why hadn't our second that motion
I'm gonna call upon counselor Ashley
thank you leader um having studied the
report I must commend the author for the
clear and precise explanation of what is
a very complex project clearly option
one to lift and shift the single system
into a cloud environment and divide the
database into each of the council's own
software is the logical way forward the
digital aspect which will allow our
tenants to be able to obtain online
information through the my account
application of their tenancy and
maintenance detail is a massive move
forward and will drastically improve the
communication process or just like it
confirmed that the one-off cost of
17,000 cloud move and 170,000 for the
system split is an equal split of the
total amount across all four councils
also the ongoing support costs of 82,000
is a substantial increase from the
previous 53,000 please could you explain
what this is in respect to and are there
any elements that could be supported by
our own in-house ICT
lastly in 2.2 of the report it states
that the document management system
module for TDC is still awaiting
deployment will this module still be
required if so will it be at an
additional cost for the future or was it
included in the previous payments thank
you either Thank You councillor Ashby
that sounds like one for the officers
miss Castle why hits desperate to answer
the technical questions because mr.
Willis or mr. Paulsen want to answer
that yes I have a grants fee in that one
Thank You Tara first of all the costs
are shared equally across the four
councils
we're just picking up quarter share and
the other figures they were reflected in
the report on the 82,000 annual
maintenance cost
we couldn't reduce the fee by carrying
out any of that work ourselves is not in
the name
two of the of the what we're paying the
82,000 for in terms of value for money I
mean we haven't got out to the market
for a fresh procurement um we would have
that would have been a very major
decision involving even higher costs
than anything longer timeframe but
because we're no vaiting the contract
what we have done is carried out some
soft market testing and that
demonstrates that Northgate is
competitive and we did shave a little
off the annual maintenance cost to
arrive at the 80 to her council um in
the 82 compared to the 53 if we can't be
having the budget isn't a great light
for light comparison um the 53 K that we
were they were that we were paying that
was in the budget is an outdated system
that hasn't been upgraded for a long
time and the 82 K will buy us cloud
hosting so we won't have to be running
it on a server and it includes future
upgrades to the system upgrades document
management system yes that is true
there's not been implemented yet we plan
to implement it we do already hold the
license for it we just need to get
around to implementing it it's a good
good example along with things like my
accounts that we can start progressing
and prioritizing once we've got doing
control of the system ourselves that was
it thanks Thank You mr. Willis and does
any other member of kavanah have any
comment they wish to make on this item
I'm not seeing any okay so it's been the
recommendation has been moved and
seconded unless I hear any objection
I'll take this this proposal was
approved and I hear no objection so we
move on to item 6 which is the tenant on
the lease holder health and safety
policies and we return to cast away
hello again and the recommendations for
this item are as follows that cabinet
agreed to adopt the proposed compliance
policies as detailed in annexes 1 3 to 6
secondly
legate authority to the head of housing
and planning in consultation with the
cabinet member for housing and safe
neighborhoods to make minor operational
changes to the policies as required and
thirdly formally reviewed the policies
every two years the reasons are as
follows
as a landlord the council has a
statutory duty to comply with relevant
legislation to protect the health and
safety of its tenants and lease holders
the policy is recommended cover the six
principal areas of health and safety
complaints where the council is required
to have an adopted policy for the
management of asbestos water hygiene
fire safety passenger lifts gas and
finally Electrical Safety it is
recommended best practice that these
policies are reviewed regularly and the
report has recommended a formal review
every two years the policies have been
prepared to be ready for the launch of
the council new in-house tenant and
lease holder service on the 1st of
October 2020s Kent Housing have been
consulted in the preparation of these
policies and will be required to deliver
services in line with these policies
during the intervening period these
policies recognize both our own
statutory obligations of landlord and
encompass best practice in terms of our
own acknowledged responsibilities I move
the recommendations of the report Thank
You councillor why had our second that
and our green councillor Rodgers Thank
You leader please could you explain why
the review will be held every two years
rather than annually as policies change
on a regular basis would it not make
sense to review every year particularly
as we're now taking this in-house thank
you okay who'd like to respond on that
Castle why Headroom I'm in terms of the
drafting legislation wise I know things
go from well between one year three to
five years and I'm happy to refer to mr.
Porter in relation to the two-year
renewal Thank You councillor whitehead
and well I think there's two things
really it's clearly at the discretion of
the council the policy that we want to
set in respect of reviewing policies
there is a significant amount of work
involved in reviewing and preparing
policy as that of this nature and we did
employ we employed consultants to advise
us about the industry best practice and
legislation about the requirement to
hold and review policies and their
advice that was 2 years and based on the
amount of work involved that's the
recommendation as well clearly we could
could do annually but it would create
significantly more significantly more
work to do that and potentially some
some cost implication we obviously
launching the new service in October and
we will it will need some time to
establish and bed in and during the
first year we're anticipating a period
of consolidation and the improvement and
but in my view I don't think we would be
ready to prepare a comprehensive policy
review after only 12 months of operation
which is why before a committee two
years thank you mr. Paul can I just ask
then I mean obviously there could be
specific changes in legislation or
specific events and we might identify
sufficient shortcomings in the policies
as a result of external changes so
presumably there's nothing to stop the
council if they wanted to make a
specific change at specific time
bringing that policy back and changing
it is there they wouldn't have to wait
for the review of all the policies now
that's you know if if at any point
there's there's a change in legislation
changing requirements
can bring something back ahead of
schedule the recommendation for two
years is that we don't leave it longer
than two years it's a it's a long stop
date effectively with a requirement that
we must review and RIA dot the policies
within two years of the most but if
something changes we need to look at it
sooner we clearly can thanks very much
any other member cabinet wants to
comment on this Ison doesn't appear so
how's the Whitehead of you said what you
need to say yes thank you very much
okay well it's been moved in seconded so
unless I hear an objection I'll take the
recommendation has approved and there
are no objections so we move on to item
7 which is the procurement of 11 new are
refuse collection freighters and it's
time for councillor album yeah Thank You
chair I'll do it the other way around
from Hillier this report is in relation
to the vehicle replacement program for
refuge writers the 2020 21 capital
program includes provision for the
replacement of a substantial proportion
of the council's refuge vehicle fleet in
accordance with the Constitution this
report seeks approval of a key decision
to commit 2.2 million pounds of the
budget allocation for the purchase of 11
26 ton freighters the council operates
them in an in-house waste and recycling
service a comprehensive vehicle
replacement program is necessary in
order for the council to meet statutory
obligations in terms of the collection
of household waste as required by the
Environmental Protection Act 1990 the
expect the expected economic life span
of a refuse collection vehicle is 7
years this is because of the heavy
nature of the work and type of low
the vehicles carry the vehicles to be
replaced were purchased in 2013 these
vehicles can no longer be economically
maintained and it will be quite simply
and it would quite simply leave the
council unable to deliver a for
household waste service if they are not
replaced options for leasing were
explored before the current capital
program was approved however this is
that this has a far higher cost and
offers less flexibility to Thanet
District Council as the end user there
is a long leading period of 40 weeks to
get in the vehicles it is therefore
important that this decision is approved
refuse vehicles are built to order and
you can't just get them off the shelf
effectively the leading period has
increased significantly due to the coded
pandemic the new open-back vehicles have
a load capacity of 10 tonnes our current
vehicles carry approximately six tonnes
this will reduce the trips to the
disposal sites the new vehicles are all
open backed which improves resilience
and also the whole fleet will be
interchangeable at six of the 11
vehicles to be replaced required
extensive body refurbishments 18 months
ago those vehicles are now suffering
similar problems again this issue will
need to be addressed before a new fleet
is delivered and officers are
considering entering options it is
imperative the new vehicles are ordered
now to reduce the duration and costs of
any interim measures and to protect the
resilience of the service I therefore
recommend to cabinet approve option 1 of
the report chair thank you thank you and
you're moving now I am moving at you yes
you look even more in that case I'll
second it thank you cancel our album and
we're bringing council Hall Thank You
leader thank you stay for economy for
that eloquent chat on that subject two
councils are trialing electric refuse
collection vehicles or are Seavey's as
they called Sheffield and Westminster
with West Westminster now going fully
electric so they obviously work with
regard to financial costs the lower
capital cost of a diesel a CV would be
largely offset by the lower running
costs of an electric our CV although the
total cost of ownership of an ER CV is
twenty nine thousand six hundred and
eight pounds greater than that of a
decent equivalent the ER Seavey's saving
would be twelve thousand three hundred
and sixty four pounds if the most if the
monetized impact of carbon emissions is
included in the real terms of our carbon
savings of approximately 250 plastic
bottles per person per year surely a
good argument for electric our CVS maybe
as a council we should be trialing the
ER CV from the company you're looking to
purchase the our CVS from before
agreeing to biodiesel wagons have you
any comment on that please thank you
Thank You councillor Hall I suspect
we're going to hear about the
practicalities of using these electric
vehicles in the streets of Planet do you
want to comment councillor Alvin or for
weed yeah I just just to come back to
count capsule at heart we dish this was
raised that the members briefing
yesterday
and and I'm very I'm very open for trial
in a vehicle if we can get an electric
vehicle if we can get the company to a
agree a short a short term use just to
try to out the C out to see our egos but
that's as far as I'm gonna answer that
it may be Gabby white can answer
anything else
Thank You chair yeah yeah I can
obviously from the briefing as well it's
yes he's not proven technology at this
moment in term and when you considering
the cost is well over two hundred
thousand pounds for vehicle it's not a
very prudent measure to be buying
vehicles that are proven technology I'm
quite sure when we've gone through the
seven-year cycle of these vehicles in
seven years the technology might have
been proven enough that actually we'd
have the confidence to buy a new fleet
eyes electric but at this moment in time
there's there's nobody using that type
of vehicle extensively anywhere in the
world as far as I'm aware in terms of
the yeah we know about the manufactures
that work we're going to purchase the
vehicles from does have an electric
vehicle so we are willing to obviously
speak to them and see if we can get one
on trial and I'm give it a go and see
see see how effective it is Thank You
mr. white
sorry I'll just come back on that sir
well okay it's only that to Sheffield
Emirates Westminster have been trying
since 2018 and I don't know if you've
been in contact with them but
Westminster now going fully electric so
so they obviously do work it's just
whether we want to take part in this
future venture and try and save the
world really well I would say that the
company that run that so it's not in
both those Westminster and Sheffield
they're run by an external company so
obviously he's the company they're
taking the risk of passing their
vehicles and it must be then that
confidence that they can deliver that
service but obviously the risk is ours
in terms of purchasing these vehicles so
obviously we'll go for the the safer
option of the diesel vehicles at this
market out I suspect that some well now
look at that Westminster and Sheffield
are also substantially larger and
wealthier authorities than the planet so
whether or not there
during the risk they will be able to
take risks themselves that Thanet
perhaps can't do but I'm sure this at
this administration would if we felt it
was practical we'll be the first to
embrace some electric vehicles in this
service because it's something we're
very very keen on as a group and I'm
sure the counselors as a whole
can I bring in councilor town in please
Thank You leader you there yes
councillor Albin
you were you're the portfolio holder of
this particular service and so you would
have been party to the setting up off
the attended document that was given to
Dennis Eagle who are the eventual
manufacturers for our vehicles it can be
good enough to tell us the cost of each
vehicle inclusive EA T or exclusivity
and could you tell me when the delivery
date will actually be I mean you've
mentioned there is a delay but what is
this current situation please thank you
you won't respond to that cows around
quiz quiz time I'm not really sure the
service can answer that because we've
done some work because actually the cost
of the vehicles is increased due to
employees inflationary pressures so I'm
sure my combi can answer that yes we
could provide that information okay
answer that quickly so the cost of each
vehicle is one hundred and ninety five
thousand nine hundred and twenty nine
pounds we thought with that we eighteen
is how much that's excluding v80 sorry
thank you I won't we expect to receive
them if you older than that sorry
okay yeah so eleven units and they would
be delivered in phases of sort two or
three units two times starting so if you
order them now it would be between
February and April next year okay thank
you
why does any member of cabinet have any
comment to make on this item doesn't
appear so so it's been moved and
seconded and I intend to take that as
approved unless I hear any objection
which I don't so
we move on to item 8 thanks the officers
to the responses to the last one
supporting our communities their
district councils plan for recovery and
this is me so since the outbreak of the
COBE of nineteen pandemic in March the
council's obviously be busy responding
to the crisis and now as the number of
cases nationally continues to fall the
government is taking steps to slowly
ease the restrictions in place and as a
council we also need to move forward and
move the both authority and district
towards recovery we will now be working
simultaneously on the recovery and
continuing the response phase and
there's also the potential of a return
to response to any time if there's a
second wave of infections it's also a
likelihood that the recovery will span
other emergency planning events
including the end of the brexit
transition phrase and the FAMAS of its
staff and partners will be working
remotely finally the sheer scale and
breadth of the social and economic
impacts on the district means that we
will be entering uncharted territory and
it's hard to predict where we will end
up so as part of this work we put
together a document supporting our
community of CDC's plan for recovery and
then this is a high-level outline of the
steps that we will take to manage our
recovery its focuses around community
and organizational leadership and the
terms of reference has been developed
for each work stream and the retractions
annexes to the report as well as the
reopening of the highest rate and beach
management action plans inevitably these
plans need to adapt what will be
constantly changing circumstances and
risks and opportunities as they arrive
and I do want to take this opportunity
to thank all the officers who've been
involved in this process because I'm
really proud of the way our officers
have responded to this crisis and the
work they've done and the service that
they've delivered to the residents of
Thalia and I hope that the whole council
is appreciative of the hard work that's
gone on here and because I think the
council has really risen to the occasion
we've also tried to be as collaborative
as possible in terms of the recovery so
we've been talking to the the town
councils and 32 Parish Council and
we've been engaging with other elected
members both through the group leaders
meetings and through the fortnightly
briefings which I know both members and
officers value and which I hope is
giving all members a sense of engagement
at a time when we haven't been able to
meet face to face as a council for a
period of months and I will say that the
feedback that we get in those briefings
has been very helpful in understanding
our shaping of the crises and what we
need to do and I'm keen that we continue
the briefings and we continue that level
of engagement which with members right
across the council it's been really
useful and I know officers feel that as
well so I'll go in erecting the
recommendation which is the cabinet
notes that the proposal it doesn't
really need to come here we brought it
here because we thought it should be
subject to democratic scrutiny there
should be a public facing document that
people can see do I have a seconder for
noting the report our second chair
thank you that's councillor Albin and
I've got a number of speakers
I've got Council of garner please thank
you thank you leader
yeah well first I'd like to echo your
comments about about members briefings
and how useful they've been and also
echo your comments and thanks to the
council officers the council how we've
responded to the crisis it's been great
because one of the impacts that this
crisis has had is is the financial
impact and its cost as I see in in
report currently four million pounds and
I note in the financial one of the
financial documents the review of the
capsule programme which on our mr.
Willis update is on the last couple of
last couple of member briefings and I
just wondered if if it be possible
together get an update on how about his
progressing and also whether included in
that review I think one of the largest
items the
we've got committed to spend is 2
million pounds on the proposed new fanuc
parkway station and whether we've been
in discussions with can count counts on
that yet whether they're whether the
viability for that station is still the
same and whether we would be likely to
consider withdrawing 2 million pound
contributions for that to help towards
more towards those than its financial
recovery itself okay thank you
Thank You counsel god I mean the short
answer to your point on the part my
station is that the council was
committed to that to spending that money
to contributing that money to the scheme
so the current state of affairs is that
that's the scheme continues and it's due
to codes of planning there's a formal
consultation out on some small design
changes that have been made but
obviously we continue to talk to Kent
County Council in terms of the financial
review mr. Willis can expand on this I
think but we are proposing to bring a
budget report to cabinet on July the
30th at which all that information will
become clear I think at the moment the
finance team mr. Willis of creating five
Rob being quite busy dealing with the
discretionary grants did you want to say
anything on that mr. woods yes thank you
chair um yeah as regards the financial
recovery um right now we're still
looking at the impact of Cobie 19 on our
budgets and finances this year and the
reports that will be going both general
fund an HRA that will be going to
cabinet at the end of July will be
dealing with this year's budget position
it will include the capital program for
this year which understandably has
suffered a huge amount of slippage
already there may be opportunities to
redirect some capital projects that were
otherwise gonna start this here but the
general more comprehensive review of the
capital program which is a four-year
program effectively I'm looking at the
2021 225 capital program that's part of
the budget process for 21 22 which we
will be starting in the autumn so
there's a bit of a longer lead in time
for the comprehend
if review of the capital program but we
will be looking at this year's capital
program as part of the reports to
cabinet at the end of July thank you
can I bring in counsel obtain Thank You
chair yes
first 1/2 of my group can I also add our
thanks to all the staff and all the key
workers I think they've done an
absolutely brilliant job and they work
so hard and they really do deserve our
thanks on the plan there are an awful
lot of words 44 pages and I was just
thinking going forward it might be
easier if we draw out some of the action
points and that she have an action plan
running alongside it
so it's clearer to understand where the
actual actions are as opposed to the
detail one thing that does concern me on
the draft cabinet report safely
reopening high streets safely reopening
high street safely fund action plan page
for 93.5 project delivery and next steps
in the third paragraph it says delivery
of the recovery program will be officer
led which doesn't really sit very
comfortably because I mean there has
been lots of criticism from the public
too often that the council is officer
LED and really it should be member LED
or member LED with the advice of the
offices or officer and member LED I just
think that that is very misleading thank
you thank you very much for the same
exact evil walter coming on that but i
would say that it's really the
difference between policy and an
operation deliveries always going to be
led by officers because we just not
equipped you know you like to get out
there with a broom but but i think in
the real world we need the officers to
deliver the services for us chief
executive would you like to comment on
that yes first of all can I just say
thank you can
going for the recognition of the stars
hard work and from you leader I think
you know they do appreciate that kind of
commentary and feedback so that is
appreciated on the yes I accept council
going the perhaps I can review the
wording I can see that why you might
have interpreted that way but the
leaders correct that's the intention of
that is about delivery operational
activity and our ability to respond
quickly to changes that that come up but
I'm happy to review it to perhaps make
it clearer that that's the intention the
intention absolutely categorically is
not to exclude members from the process
at all thank you Thank You councillor
pew Thank You leader yes yeah I have a
few questions specifically on economic
recovery and the high street fund so
I'll I'll kind of I'll do them all all
in all in one go and everything and
hopefully I don't lose you all along the
way and in a long sweeping monologue but
yeah particularly on the economic
recovery recovery and particularly you
know this lockdown and the pandemic is
unlike anything that any of us have ever
seen and of course it's going to be
important for us as accounts offer for
residents and and for businesses to
adapt and to be able to support all of
our local small businesses as much as we
can and I commend the council for that
but particularly one of my questions is
is how long will the support continue on
fall is it particularly with the small
businesses in our communities I have a
feeling that the issues that we've had
with the lockdown and and how businesses
and communities have been impacted you
know he's gonna carry on for quite some
time really and I think you know if
we're only looking at a program of you
know three six months 12 months in the
long term I hope that we can look at
that more realistically particularly
over the next 2-3 years and the support
that the community our communities will
need and also be intrigued to know how
closely we're going to be working with
the County Council particularly on
economic development and driving forward
because of course they still have quite
a vital role to play particularly in
working with us and doing that so I
think
incredibly important that we work
side-by-side with them also as well I'm
intrigued to know how much contact we've
had with central government particularly
to do with our economic recovery in the
department a couple a couple years ago I
think it was a lourdes committee came
down and and viewed Margate in
particular it was kind of a shining
example of regeneration in our kind of
coastal communities and I had been
treated to know what the council has
done to kind of signpost that
to central government in the department
and and kind of show us as a case for
you know as an exceptional case in the
support that we need in kind of
reinvigorating places such as Margate
and Ramsgate Rose des but also as well
Drive and fall with that change that we
want to see within the towns and then
going on to the high street funds ryokan
high street fund and i understand that
we're limited by funds and the fact that
we've been given for this and that it's
been allocated to it but particularly
the main high streets that are going to
be reopened i completely understand that
but you know is this going to be in one
block funding or is it going to be kind
of staggered to kind of help kind of
stretch out the kind of impact that it
could have for reopening the high
streets because some businesses may not
be able to reopen as soon as possible
and of course gonna have to follow
government and government guidance and
advice and also as well I understand
that we're targeting more of the main
kind of high street centers but I think
we're really missing a trick here with
the smaller kind of shopping centers
particularly areas particularly Minster
some pieces and Westbrook I know there's
a few others that have been named on
there but I think particularly for
elderly and vulnerable residents across
the district you know not just in my
ward but across the district a lot of
them use places like some Peters and
Minster for their kind of little
shopping and stuff like that and and
very regularly will they venture further
out to the main high streets and the
shopping centers and I think that we're
missing a trick there in supporting them
thank you can't stop here
I mean I'll deal with some of those
points and then I bring in offices I
think in terms of supporting businesses
away from the high street fund yes the
council will obviously do what he can to
support businesses and be particularly
by creating the right environment for
them but I think the real question is
for the Chancellor probably
than for us because those businesses I
think some of them are probably hanging
on because of the business grants
they've had from central government and
if central government support falls off
a cliff and one can well understand that
central government can't keep pumping
money into the economy then that is
going to be the biggest factor in
whether our businesses survive and
thrive but then it will be doing what it
came in terms of the county council well
obviously we do talk to the county
council and the two execs who will
expand on that but I can tell you that
you know I was in a meeting this morning
with Mike whiting and we were talking
very specifically about some potential
developments in fanuc which will be
exciting which can't go in super so we
are liaison with KC's T in terms of
national government and telling the
story well there's a job there for the
for the two MPs for four Thanet and the
to be exact and I and
Tim Willits have been speaking to them
on a weekly basis and I think that's
been constructive I mean obviously I
have my differences with them
politically but I think that no they
would agree that those meetings have
been constructive we've been able to
share information and we've encouraged
them to take the message back from fanox
essential government about what we need
you know and you know hopefully they'll
be doing that but certainly that's been
a positive relationship and you know I
think it's something
another thing has come out the pandemic
instead of meeting the two MPs every
three months or whatever we've been
meeting them on a weekly basis and
that's been useful in terms of
understanding each other apart from
anything else and it's in terms of the
high street 126 hours and I think one of
the problems is that the advice from
government was quite prescriptive and he
didn't actually arrive very early but it
isn't a huge amount of money so if we
spread it too thin you there's danger
about having you know no effect at all
but I'm certainly mindful of that you
know I know Minster very well I'm
mindful at Minster and some other
shopping centers but I think we've got
to we've got to be careful that we get
the maximum value for the money that we
have got available and there
unfortunately there's some quite strict
limitations as to what we can spend it
on chief executive jimana come in I
think that was quite good summary I
would just add a couple of points if I
may just go back to actually cancel
games point about action plans I just
want to reassure you we do have some
detailed operational plans
that are supporting our recovery
activity so just to provide some
reassurance about that that we're using
as a working tool for officers to
actually progress things and monitor and
evaluate our progress against that in
respect of councillor views questions I
just wanted to add a couple of things
obviously the economic recovery totally
except that this is a long term not just
a short term activity
I think our recovery plan by its nature
is inevitably kind of has short medium
long term aspirations in it so just to
provide reassurance that obviously we'll
be continuing to support businesses and
the economy both over the short and
medium term we are working very closely
the KCC which you would absolutely
expect us to do because clearly KCC have
a clear role around a strategic economic
activity our relationship is very good
we kick KCC particularly around the
economy I would suggest clearly they
have strong relationships with locating
Kent which is important to us around
helping to encourage investment into
into the area we are also feeding into
through Kent Chiefs we have access to
KCC's economic recovery cell so and Kent
Chiefs regularly discussed the company
and our approaches to that central
government absolutely as said we are
continue to update the emplyees we're
also as you will recall a part of the
town deal and Ramsgate high street
funding which clearly our government
central government linked we do have a
positive relationship with government
departments including a relationship
that I have directly with a senior
member within m8 CLG so we are in
regular contact central government but
it's a useful point could we do more
it's worth thinking about maybe we could
attempt to organize a discussion in due
course when things have calmed down a
bit about how we can continue to work
with central
and around some of the funding and
activities we're also looking to engage
with our colleagues within East Kent
around some of the Freeport consultation
that's going on and opportunities that
that might provide we are part of these
Kent growth strategy growth of boards
which again is with Ares can't call it a
colleague so there is an awful lot going
on around high speed one the parkway
station all of the assets that we have
in East Kent and how we'd pull them
together and make them that much more
sense we're working very closely with
KCC around an infrastructure deal and
East Kent is a real driver for that so
there are lots of discussions going on
around driving the economy so just to
provide some reassurance about that yes
the 126 thousand pounds around the high
street fund not a whole can of beans
really when you think about it we do
need to be smart about how we use those
funds and actually this is a case of
claiming back as we spend over a period
of time because this is ERDF money and
yes there are some very prescriptive
requirements attached to it which is
quite frustrating because really most of
us would have liked a bit more freedom
about how we could apply that funding
but it is the nature of the beast and I
want to reassure you that we will try
and use it sensibly over a sensible
period of time
we're already looking to discuss in due
course around Phase two of that spending
to support some of the leisure and
hospitality businesses coming back on in
the beginning of July and yeah we are
talking to parish councils I talked to
parish councils once every two two weeks
and we are engaged with I literally had
a meeting with them this morning around
high streets actually everything seems
to be going quite smoothly but of course
if they're only asks from any of our any
parts of our district we're willing to
hear them and work with the parish
councils on those issues thank you thank
you chief executive and and I will say
that I think the input from members
particularly the local knowledge of
members is very useful in the recovery
phase in terms of what's going on in
local areas and we're listening and
we'll try and adapt our strategy to meet
the things that you tell us because we
can't be everywhere officers can't be
everywhere
members on the ground sometimes the best
source of information that we've got so
that's it's been moved and seconded that
we note the report unless I hear any
objection I will take it as noted nobody
wants to object to that
so can I thank everybody officers and
members for their time this evening and
I think it's been a very good discussion
that concludes the business for tonight
and I declare the meeting closed at 1758
by making it the livestream of this
meeting will now end thank you